you have these
people go on facebook or whatever and
their friends are like are you gonna
come down to protest because we're gonna
go
protest the mayor and they're like oh my
god that's so cool i totally want to
protest
and they show up and then they're handed
a sign because typically they'll make a
bunch of signs and hand them out
and then you get these really dumb you
know 20-somethings who are like
i'm mad about something i've never
researched i met about something i've
never researched
that's so accurate though yes and then
you organize it that is it right there
then the organizers open up the gate to
a private lot and they go
right this way my friends and they're
like yeah i'm mad i have no idea where
i'm going but you go ahead i'm gonna
wait out here
on the the legal where we're legally
allowed to protest i'm sure that's what
happened too
and then why are these people yelling
it's a it's a public street
because they have no idea what's
happening around them exactly
it's dangerous man but it's very clear
the no trespassing sign yep
it's on the dc right in the front of the
gate it's like no trespasses the only
sign on the gate let me tell you a story
man uh when i was like 16 i think
i got asked by some chick off like
myspace or something to come with her to
a protest okay
it was it was an iraq war protest i
think in chicago okay and i was like
yeah i'm down i
i hate the war right yeah sure i want to
get laid well no for me i was like
i was like i'm just messing with you man
good i was like dude i was i was punk
rock i was writing all these punk rock
songs
and i was like yeah f4 yeah and so i
showed up
and we like marched around and like the
loop or whatever
some far lefty you know dudes maybe i
can't remember how
maybe i was 17 or 18. but these like you
know far lefty types and all black were
shoving cops knocking them down
and like the bleeding heart type hippie
liberals who were organizing it got
angry and they're like stop stop don't
do this and like push them away yeah and
like
help the cop back up we marched around
and then finally
we got to i think it's it was grant park
millennial park whatever they named it
okay and then someone announced the
protest is now going to join the
teachers strike
and i was like what the the what now the
teachers teachers
college professors were striking at a
nearby university so they were like
everybody go join them
and i was like what i was like i don't
care about their
salaries yeah i'm talking about war in a
foreign country
they all went up and joined them wow and
so i stopped and then some of the
some of these like pharmacy types were
struggling behind and once they started
to walk into the park
this one woman turns around she goes are
you coming you're gonna join us
and i got really angry and i was like
they're talking about getting more money
for their six-figure cushy job or
whatever as tenured professors yeah and
we're talking about
war in a foreign country and i was i
just snapped an hour overlapping
if these people and if anybody who's
gonna walk away i'm going to keep them
i'm going to keep walking
yeah and i was by myself and i just left
and i was like that was really
disillusioning for me i was like these
people don't know what they're talking
about
right these people who were marching
just joined a strike and then pretended
like they knew why any of these people
cared and i was like get out of here
dude you have no idea what you're
talking about
you've done no research you have no idea
who these people are you have no idea
what they're fighting for and you just
go and stand there
it's because it's because of the cool
points they want to be cool
what's cool standing up for for the
minority
standing up against the man it's like
one of the guys who's talking about
his car or something it's like his car
is broken
it's like unless you actually know the
research and understand what you're
doing
what are you doing so that's why that's
why in my family the funniest thing is
the posts coming from the white part of
my family are all like we have to be
good allies and stand up and fight for
the rights of people and the posts
coming from the asian side of my family
are like trump is clearly in the right
on this one and i'm like what is wrong
with everyone what is going on this is
not supposed to be this way
you'd think it'd be the white people
being like how i'm i'm very fragile
haram
how dare you challenge my status and the
poor minorities would be like we need
help because the evil whites
no it's not even like that i get hit up
by the the asian part of my family very
often just being like
america yeah not all of them not all of
them
i love it but but it's just nothing you
know what man
nothing makes sense and so you have
right now
you have you have you have way it comes
and goes and waves i guess and one of
the things i've said is like
republicans happen to be right it's not
so much republicans at all actually
it's the conservatives tend to be right
it's the people in the middle of the
bell curve
we got the left we got the right and
then we have most of
everybody who's like what is going on
with what they'll crazy people
they'll shift a little to the left a
little to the right back and forth yeah
sure sure
and so sometimes the stance of life you
have the left and sometimes it's the
right
right now it's like i you know it's it's
disheartening to see jon stewart
clearly have no idea what he's talking
about oh no he's been so out of the game
for so long it's like
yeah that's just it's where are the i
mean
bill maher still exists it's weird
because he's got trump derangement
syndrome very
severely but he he calls it out
correctly
like so often that's true yeah i said
some really dumb things about the
economy
yes he's like if a recession gets rid of
trump bring on the recession it's like
you realize people die in the recession
right yeah right but at least he's uh
wha what was what was what was the most
recent thing he talked about i can't
remember
it was something about white people stop
being offended for other people yeah
that's exactly what he was saying
i would love that he's like how do we i
mean it's not just white people come on
there's
it's anyone anyone can sure there's no
denying that but
it's like any anyone can have that
complex where they have to be offended
for someone else it's like
you gotta just let that go come on you
know the funny thing about white
fragility is
what that book the book is that like the
most fragile white people are the people
who are
promoting that book yeah yeah that's
true for real though look
this justifies why i'm so fragile well
there's a video of a white woman
a black female cop and she's holding up
a sign and screaming and the back of the
cardboard just holding says fragile on
it i know i was like that's just so
perfect it's pretty good
and then someone somebody asks they're
filming they're like do you not see the
problem with you yelling at this black
woman and she's like
she's part of the system i i can fight
racism i
have to do it and it's like you are so
fragile you snap in
in two seconds and they all do they all
snap it's an emotional
trigger that they just go i'm like whoa
whoa i was just trying to have a logical
conversation with you
it happens all the time it's crazy you
know that rick and morty episode
where rick is making a little robot i
don't
know
at the breakfast table oh yes and then
he makes a little robot and then the
robot goes
what is my purpose to spin the ufo i
meant and he goes
you pass you pass butter or no no it
goes past the butter and it pushes it
and then goes what is my purpose
you pass butter and it looks his hands
and goes oh my god
i laughed so hard when i first saw that
but it reminds me of like what do you
think would happen
when all of these like fringe lefty woke
white women
who are leading the charge because it is
it is like a large proportion the
plurality of this group is white women
when they realize they're the karen's
they they want all the attention no what
what do you think they do when they
realize they're the karens
when like the karen was you the whole
time oh man as it is
there's think about it i'll like a
picture is that that one
uh woman getting on her knees and
screaming no
right now think about this how many how
many videos have been released of
karen's
oh so many but but in the single digits
in the past year right oh i don't know
five really probably more than that
there's the there's there's there's the
the the woman in the park with the dog
yeah there's the woman with the guy with
the black lives matter on his porch
what else i've seen a few like in stores
there's a lady who got slapped across
the face by hispanic lady for calling
her names and a bunch of other
middle-aged ladies get in trouble with
by calling people names but so it's not
that that many of the high profile
carrying moments yeah there's been like
single digits yeah that's true yeah now
that's because
it's probably not that many karen's
minority you gotta let me finish oh
goodness these these videos
of white women at protests screeching on
top of their lungs
demanding the supervisor from the police
yelling
um patriarchy over the past several
years so we've been seeing
so we are seeing karen's all over the
place right that's what you're saying
the point i'm making is there's all
sorts of them
when they promote these like racist
cairns there's like
seven and when we see videos of these
sjw karen's there's like
oh three thousand oh my gosh exactly
she's she's a karen queen
classic yeah big red you know big red
patriarchy
man these look you see that video of the
woman screeching at the black woman
holding the fragile sign yeah that's a
karen
totally what's the difference she's
she's screaming at a black woman
look you you you showed me a video about
black lives matter right
seriously you show me a video
of a white woman screaming at a minority
and say it's a karen
and then you show me the same thing from
the black rise matter activists and i'm
like why is that not occurring it's
literally the same components you're
right
and there's way more way way more videos
of white women screaming at black people
they're still mine from the left
they're still minorities who are those
karens what do you mean minorities those
are
it's a minority group who are the new
age karens that's a minority
what do you mean a minority you mean the
majority of humans
in america i mean we're talking american
politics right now so it's like
i i think the amer the american woman is
a majority
over the minority karen screamers that
we're seeing
68 of millennial women are democrats
sure but millennials make up how much of
the population compared to all of humans
it's well gen z is the biggest ever
every next generation
is the is bigger than the previous sure
cairns exists but
millennials everyone's pointing at them
going wow look at those cairns
except when it's leftist karen's which
is the overwhelming majority of karen's
yeah that's the point because they're
not self-aware they haven't yet realized
the character they were there in the
whole time
yeah so that's the point i'm making like
oh man what do you think happens
when they finally have this like reality
snap where they look at their hands like
i'm a karen it's me
do you think they are they're all going
to be in a room just ringing at each
other
they're all going to be demanding the
manager oh my gosh i want to speak to
your manager
he just keeps going down around like
well if you want to speak to my manager
i want to speak to your manager
and then it turns out there it's a loop
of managers
it's a it's a big circle of cairns and
each karen in front of them is their own
manager he's like oh my goodness
and so they're like they turn around
who's your manager that's my manager i
want to speak with your manager then it
finally comes back to them they're like
i'm the manager but you're my manager
but
i have the character cue the spider-man
meme of them pointing at each other
exactly what
i have seen i have seen look i've seen
way more videos of angry white women
screaming at minorities from the left
than i have from
anything i want all the attention that's
all i'm seeing right there
i wonder why it is like what is it toxic
femininity
no it's because everyone wants to be
valued at the core
of us as as human beings we want to be
appreciated loved and needed
i don't care who you are you want that
you want to be you want to have a
purpose
if we don't have any of those things we
go a little cuckoo
people are going cuckoo have you seen
that the video the woman with the
fragile
sign right yeah yeah i've seen that the
look on her eyes man yeah
they're she's like bugged out like right
it's when you you lose
you don't have a purpose and your your
screws start getting
really loose and then they start popping
off yeah and then everything just starts
jumbling apart and then you
are crazy that maybe you get that or
perhaps their brains were taken over by
alien brain slugs
and that explains ufos thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm if you want to
catch the
full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode